hello readers today we shall take the
field in rhetorical combat also known as
argument
argument is when an author wants to
convince you of their position
this is my position you should share
this position and here is why argument
does not sneak it does not come in
through the back it is supported by
reasons evidence examples not just pure
opinion not just cherry-picked stories
data fact observable reality there is a
place for pure subjective opinion and is
the realm of the movie and the
restaurant review
i did not like this movie because i
didn't laugh at its jokes
i did not enjoy the hamburger i got
because i found it too dry for my liking
this is not what we're talking about
today
obviously argument is rooted in opinion
and subjective personal preferences but
those opinions need to be backed up with
evidence
let's compare arguments for and against
attacks on soda now this writer argues
that sugar contributes to obesity and
therefore people should be prevented
from buying soda which is full of sugar
on the ground that it is bad for them
let's take a look
the soda tax could alter many people's
behavior causing them to stop buying
sugary drinks some foods are necessities
like milk eggs and bread people will buy
them even if the prices increase
sugary drinks aren't necessary if the
price goes up people will buy fewer
sugary drinks and they won't be
consuming as much sugar therefore the
obesity rate will go down
whereas this author counters that people
have a right to make what they see as
unhealthy decisions soda and other
sugary drinks have been targeted because
they lack nutrition and are basically
just liquid sugar most people would
agree that proper nutrition is important
for maintaining a healthy lifestyle
however do legislators have the right or
responsibility to regulate people's
sugar intake in order to improve their
health i say no all right let's evaluate
these claims for the first argument in
favor of the soda tax how do we know
this is true what evidence does this
author give that this tax will alter
people's behavior what evidence does
this author give that sugary drinks
aren't seen to be as essential as milk
after all not everyone can or does drink
milk in the piece the evidence that the
author gives us is this table which
shows how much sugar is in soda per
serving but it doesn't use evidence to
connect sugar consumption to unhealthy
outcomes all this says is soda has a lot
of sugar i want to see evidence i want
to see studies how do we know this tax
would change behavior
good readers think through the impacts
of an argument if this tax went into
effect what would the consequences be
are there faults in the author's logic
it might stop some people from buying
soda but in an unfair way here's how i'm
processing this as a reader if you take
a bottle of soda that previously cost
say 2
and the tax makes it ten dollars that
will make it more difficult to purchase
but to a millionaire the difference
between two dollars and ten dollars is
basically nothing whereas to a poor or
middle class person that eight dollar
difference adds up pretty quickly
i see this as a possible unintended
consequence of this proposal that it
hits poor people harder than rich people
as readers it's not just our
responsibility to interpret what the
author's saying we also have to ask
ourselves what are they not saying
in the second argument the author is
arguing that it isn't the government's
responsibility to determine how much
sugar people consume and therefore taxes
on sugary drinks are unnecessary so now
i'm asking whose responsibility is it to
determine how much sugar is in a drink
why is sugar so inexpensive to begin
with do legislators have a
responsibility there now we know it's
not legal to bottle rat poison and sell
it as t but whose responsibility is that
what isn't this author saying and how
does not saying it serve their argument
they're not saying what the government
could or should do only what it
shouldn't do and this is why i want you
to be skeptical whenever you read
anyone's argument about anything
you need to figure out what the terms of
the debate are what does the argument
assume as a given what's what's a
problem worth fixing what are the
trade-offs that the writer thinks are
acceptable so when you encounter an
argument in text look for the claims and
then look to see if those claims are
backed up with data supported reasoning
is the author using evidence and logic
do they anticipate objections to their
arguments and push back on or
incorporate those critiques
above all else i want you to remain
skeptical everyone's selling something
even me it's just the thing i'm trying
to sell you is the fundamental idea that
you can learn anything
you've got this readers
dave it out